the first day of the second month of
2021
is when the show comes back that's when
i come back the first day of the second
month you
you know which you know which month that
is okay truth be told i didn't want to
start my first video back in a while by
potentially mispronouncing
february february it's a hard word for
me
black history month first black history
month first
will be the first show back 10 a.m
eastern um
feb for those who have to abbreviate
everything i know it's been a spell
um i appreciate most of you uh pardoning
our dust um some of you haven't i
understand that too
uh usually we take a month break you
know mid december through early january
we'll be going on on
with this break three weeks longer than
anticipated um
and i've had to go to to radio silence
uh
mostly you know out of necessity for
those who still uh are subscribed to you
know crowder bits or instagram or
twitter we've
uh posted some stuff there but um yeah
for three main reasons and let me rattle
them off
let me rattle them off see this is what
happens when i'm my tongue isn't uh
it's not used to going a mile a minute
really not necessarily a mile a minute
isn't really that
fast when you think about that
expression
a mile a minute that's again i don't
want to do math correctly but i think
it's just it's not that fast i mean
there's a speed limit in many places
um three things
twins major lawsuit heart problem okay
in no particular order of importance let
me go through them here
um this is why we've we've been delayed
myself really in particular
um if you followed the program last year
you know that uh my wife uh
had a miscarriage um we talked about it
but greater length with mark driscoll on
the last ash wednesday of the year
and i don't say that for for sympathy i
say it because i know that many of you
out there have gone through that
experience or
are going through it right now and uh i
know that it can be
tough it was tough and i see it because
there is hope because now
mrs crowder is going to have two little
crowders look at this there's baby
there's baby a
this is at nine weeks baby a and there's
this is this is baby b ab
ab were calling him look at that look at
that little club foot he's got my fred
flintstone feet already or she
i'm hoping it's a he with that clip foot
kind of looks like the little uh little
character et in the atari game which
destroyed many childhoods forever
um and uh i i well so we had another
close call with almost lost both of
these twins
and uh that required a little a little
more of my time and attention here
uh but that's not that's not the primary
reason that uh that we've had to be um a
little bit of hypothesis by the way uh
give me some names that you guys would
like i've been
i'm particularly fond of magnus if it's
a if it's a boy magnus crowder
uh i also like evander but i don't wanna
i mean i don't want to put on him
uh foreshadow an ear being bitten but i
like evander and i like magnus and if
it's a girl
um i've just we've thought of heather
just because
uh my french canadian mom can't
pronounce h's or
th's so enter give me a good name that
would be a fun prank for
my my mom i would just you know what i
will name my child
whatever name you can come up with with
the most h's and fuzz
just to bust my mom's chops uh the other
thing major lawsuit
so this has been going on behind the
scenes and um before we get to my my
heart problem which is
the primary reason and uh the lawsuit
look
we come back black history month first i
i want to make something clear if you're
looking for a show that just talks about
how much biden sucks um
this is not the show for you
former vice president joe biden does
suck
and i do think he shows some signs of
cognitive decline i'm not
i'm not speculating i'll have my doctor
on i have a neurologist on to talk about
it
um and yes listen uh president joe biden
of course the uh
the mainstream media uh oh really
they're not so mainstream anymore which
we'll get to in a second
um hollywood they're they're uh
they're a primary adversary
but a lot of republicans did nothing
okay for four years
did nothing and i'm not just talking
about the election which uh you know
we've covered at length
here on the program as a matter of fact
some of those some of the information
the amicus briefs came
from yours truly and i shouldn't be
doing that
um republicans had four years and they
did nothing about the biggest issue of
our time big tech
uh the i guess sort of tripopoly for
lack of a better word but the
the corporate censorship the foreign
interference that can take place
rules and guidelines that are really
important as we go into the next decade
all the tweets all the hearings
all the subpoenas nothing was done as
far as big tech is concerned
they are undefeated against republicans
and we are filing a major lawsuit
february first i bring this up with
republicans because you know what listen
uh they're not our friends i i know
there's the 11th commandment that ronald
reagan spoke about and andrew breitbart
reiterated to me that you shouldn't uh
speak ill of your fellow conservative
but um not all of them were the team
jersey
and of course former vice president joe
biden is is
uh he's really not the main problem in
the country he's a symptom of
of the problems going on right now um
but
at what point is it no longer the same
team jersey and we've had conversations
with some of these people who hold
legislative power behind the scenes
and have seen them kowtow because
they're afraid of losing maybe
their little slice of platform well
listen big tech thinks that they're
undefeated because
they think that they're untouchable all
the tweets nothing nothing has happened
but by the end of this year they're
going to have a half asian kraken in
their l column
okay of that you can be certain uh
details we can't talk about now again
uh black history month first and um
republicans you know people don't
remember this i was around when barack
obama
was inaugurated i was a commentator at
fox news when the tea party was started
uh you know the rant from santelli and i
remember republicans always they were
painted as the party of no they were
painted as a party that's all i did no
and i defended them sometimes and this
of course doesn't doesn't apply to all
republicans
but that criticism was right it seems
that a lot of republicans would rather
be the party of no
than uh actually use their power for
good when they have it and
and this is something that's important
you won't only be
judged by what you did when you were
powerless you'll be judged by what you
did
uh with strength with power once you
attained it
and uh it's been disappointing for me
but we have uh we
we've had to get ready for this lawsuit
there was there was some look okay
i'll say this uh i'll say this once
and i will you'll never hear me say it
again
this has been the number one
conservative show across media platforms
uh with a bullet for a while now
it's not even close and we don't come
out and say that because you hear some
of these shows say number one show or
top growing
fastest growing show because we want the
show to be to be judged on on the merits
of its content
okay sorry i had to do a quick cut
because a plane was going by overhead
and uh there's not even an airport
here that's well someone must be
crashing uh that's unpleasant
um but yeah i say this because i think
that's what i was talking about content
is more important but we've had a really
big target on our back
and there have been some uh
times where we zigged where had we
zagged
over the course of the last month and a
half we would have lost everything
i mean i mean you wouldn't even be able
to see this broadcast pseudo broadcast
whatever you call this right now
and uh i i can't explain we've been very
blessed i can't explain it there's been
a rhyme and a reason
and it's it's time to get serious i'm
not just talking about a suit of
post was removed but hopefully something
that sets um a serious precedent to give
you an example so election night
election night and election morning we
had 15 something million people
uh tune in and that was
keep in mind that was after facebook had
completely banned removed our stream
without reason which by the way we still
have not been given so who knows you
know if we'd just be able to
reach the people who have chosen to
subscribe and and and like our pages
call it maybe 20 million um and i don't
say that to brag that's why we don't
bring it up i say it because i'm
incredibly grateful
and it's relevant here because there
were some powers that be
that were very upset that we had
uh more people tuning in than any of
their main anchors
at abc cbs cnn fox news
um and
the landscape is about to change and
we've had to ready aim fire a lot of
people are going off
firing too much it's been a ready aiming
season
and um black history month the first
we'll be able to get into some details
uh well my half asian lawyer will be
there and i think landau
too which reminds me will be um also uh
bringing in some uh
some new talent here um on a full-time
basis
at uh at uh mud club ladder with crowder
which
brings me to my my final reason look the
a big reason that um we broke a little a
little earlier than uh
the nevada stream which we were planning
on doing
was yeah i've come into uh the knowledge
of
a pretty serious uh heart issue heart
chest issue um and i know for people no
no it's not
it's not from the occasional cigar let
me be really clear it's
genetic it's mechanical and it likely
will
require um what's the opposite of
minimally invasive surgery
um i don't uh on a maximum pleasantness
surgery uh so let me let me kind of
start backwards here a little bit
this was discovered accidentally and i'm
sure it was exacerbated by uh as a
matter of fact i took a break about
three years ago
for some similar health issues and um we
now know that they
might have been misdiagnosed i've just
sort of had to compensate and live with
it
um i had what i
thought were uh repeated panic attacks
and that's just because people didn't
really know what it was
and we'll actually have footage when we
come back here uh february 1st to show
you the
off air where i was sort of describing
these things um
and i'm sure it wasn't helped by the
fact that i was going on about three
four hours sleep most nights
from election until we we ended up going
on break uh that's not good for you
um i don't take pride in that that's bad
you should sleep
it's not a good thing it doesn't make
you tough um it's a problem
and i i uh i have had panic attacks in
my life let me be clear
but i can count them on one hand the
amount of times that i've had panic
attacks
and i can trace them as to why you know
i i had this feeling
but it got to a point where these things
were just happening repeatedly and um
and i was waking up with them
um and i think we have this footage at
the studio where i would be saying like
gosh my heart just feels like it's
feels like it's flattering it feels
going to be down on my chest and getting
faint and uh
when i spoke with doctors but this was a
panic attack uh
but i'm not really necessarily i'm tired
but i'm not necessarily stressed not
like in the past where i've had panic
attacks
and we've even had to compensate on the
show for months now
where i take five or ten minutes and do
the sort of deep breathing before the
show
and then after the show five or ten
minutes because i kept getting winded
and uh feeling light-headed and when i
would go and drink from my mug that was
a signal for someone else to say
something because i'd be going
like a really uh you know like like like
like a fat guy like a fatter
guy comment section and uh
we just see there's another plane
there's a plane crashing someone is
about to die
and that's always a tragedy i don't care
who you are um
i uh it just popped up on an ekg and an
ecg now
the reason that this has been extended
through the break is not because i
couldn't necessarily do the show with
these uh
sort of these heart flutters sort of
pseudo-panic attacks um which i don't
want to i don't want to get into exactly
what it is because i don't want to
misspeak
but i have had to go through five
doctors because it's incredibly
rare and i didn't want to come back and
stutter step come back
and have to stop or give you an
explanation that was an incorrect
explanation
because i didn't want to drag you guys
don't need to be dragged through that
it's like look i need to hit the seat
and and do the show it's severe enough
i'll tell you this that if i were in
another job and didn't run a business
i'd be able to collect disability
indefinitely
that's not what i want to do that's not
what we plan on doing um
and because of covid things kept
changing if i were to have a
cardiac uh collapse or or issue
right now that required me attention i
could get this this surgery i could get
the care
but other because that is not the case
it's not essential
maybe it will be now um
i didn't really have answers until and i
still don't necessarily have answers
we're about 90
there uh i'm very very fortunate in that
finally i was referred to a specialist
the foremost specialist in the country
at mayo clinic and i'll be going there
uh
this week for three days but at a
certain point i just had to pull the
trigger and said look
listen it doesn't matter what's what's
going on here this this
can has been kicked down the trail i'm
going to start the show
uh black history month first regardless
of what happens at mayo because when i
have to get into the operation it could
be april it could be fall who knows
and that's what we've put in place
people who will be
joining mod club uh i'm not i'm not
going to say who
uh we'll be able to sub-host when that
does happen i have no idea
uh where we are with that on the horizon
but uh it was a scary spell
uh i'm glad that we have the health care
system that we do here in the united
states where i was able to
get to an expert um whose opinion at
least at this point seems to be
correct and i and i am grateful that uh
i'll be able to come back and listen
this is this is one of those things
where i hate all the other crap that
comes with this
okay all the legal stuff that's not fun
all the business stuff that i have to do
that's not fun uh none of that is is
is fun having to juggle you know life in
in public or you know some of you have
privacy i don't necessarily know
if you have twins or russian triplets i
have no idea um i don't know why they
would be russian if you're not russian
but you could be
um no idea what your health situation is
like but i'm not you know i'm not
necessarily afforded that luxury
and and rightfully so i understand it
um because we've all sort of let you
into our life and and
and i think that's actually a wonderful
thing that's a wonderful thing
it's one of the best aspects of of new
media for the viewer
um that's why legacy media wants to kill
it
it's also one of the hardest to juggle
uh for the content creator
especially uh someone who wants to focus
on the content
not on social media drama so uh black
history month
first um and we're still waiting on info
look i can promise you this
that chair that desk is where i want to
be
[Music]
it is where i'm going to be and behind
the scenes
fill your hands you sons of [ __ ]
figuratively
because we're coming for all of it black
history month first
i appreciate you guys waiting and we'll
have more content
um than ever and hopefully some new
voices that i'm looking forward to
to showcasing and of course the half
asian kraken